so I think 400 imports Sofia they're all
really invested enough to know when it's
best to go their separate ways
yeah according to multiple reports Scott
Disick and Sofia Ricci have called it
quits the couple has decided to take
some time apart
as Scott works through his past trauma I
think you just gotta figure out really
what's important to you at the end of
the day on May 4th
eet's he learned that the reality star
checked into a treatment center in
Colorado that same day his lawyer
released a statement that Scott had
already checked himself out of the
facility after photos taken of him on
the premises were leaked online I
figured this would be the move to make
though Scott has previously struggled
with substance abuse his attorney said
that he had been working on hilling his
past traumas including the back-to-back
deaths of his parents in 2013 and 2014
you know I think when my parents passed
it was just too hard to talk about in a
preview for an upcoming episode of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians Scott
also revealed that he's having a hard
time being in quarantine
amid the corona virus pandemic when news
broke earlier this month that Scott seek
treatment a source told etes he that
quote Sophia was a big proponent in
having Scott in a rehab in Colorado at
the end of the day Scott needs to be
clean to be around his children and
family and that's everyone's main focus
right now Scott and Sophia began dating
in September of 2017 which was about two
years after he and the mother of his
three kids Kourtney Kardashian called it
quits I think the real part is life is a
challenge last year to flip it like
Disick star opened up to et about how
he's learned to navigate life and
relationships if you work at what you
want you can get it but it takes hard
work simple as that you can easily live
less of a life without working as hard
and that's up
[Music]